nein es ist kein vergnügen morgens im
halbdunkel durch das nasskalte paris zu
radeln
wer sich dennoch in den berufsverkehr
einreiht so wie ich will schneller oder
überhaupt mal ankommen denn seit wochen
stehen metro still und autos im stau
viele franzosen setzen seitdem aufs
fahrrad
fahrräder unterwegs derzeit aber das
wegenetz ist auch inzwischen besser
deshalb geht es eigentlich ganz gut mit
dem rad am seeufer entlang das ist schon
etwas besonderes ich glaube ich mache
das auch nach dem streik weiter
man muss schon sehr aufpassen und darf
nicht zu schnell fahren und bei der
sicherheitsausrüstung sollte man auf
keinen fall sparen auch ich wage mich
nur mit helm und warnweste durch den
dichten verkehr und nehme wo es geht
eine abkürzung über autofreie plätze die
hat es nicht auf die fahnen geschrieben
paris zur fahrradhauptstadt von
frankreich zu machen der streik kommt
ihr jetzt natürlich zugute
viele nehmen die neu angelegten
fahrradwege sehr dankbar an aber längst
nicht überall läuft es rund
die straßen werden immer voller zehn
stationen verzeichnen rekorde 40 prozent
mehr radfahrer seit streikbeginn und
damit steigen auch die unfallzahlen bei
dem dichten verkehr ist es im notfall
mitunter schwer durchzukommen
olivera small beobachtet den wandel in
der stadt jetzt zu streikzeiten zeigt
sich besonders wie sehr auto und
radfahrer aber auch fußgänger um ihren
platz im öffentlichen raum kämpfen
damit sich das fahrrad wirklich
durchsetzt müsste noch einiges passieren
die pasok und toni ländern beobachtet
wie sich die neuen fahrradfahrer
durchschlagen müssen
es ist voll man muss ständig aufpassen
da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob sie
auch nach dem streik dabei bleiben die
stadt muss mir tun damit sie das rad
dauerhaft nutzen
der ausbau der fahrradstrecken ist ein
zentrales thema dem derzeitigen
kommunalwahlkampf diese schnellstraße
ist bereits autofrei und hier wird sie
mit schönen ausblicken belohnt meine
nicht ganz stressfreie tour durch paris
in zeiten des streiks